das ist ja der komplette wahnsinn guckt
ihr euch an
ja hallo
ich habe mich gerade meine eigenen
spucke verschluckt
und david herzlich willkommen hier heute
meine damen und herren ihr könnt jetzt
schon sehr herzlich willkommen hier
heute zu der zweiten episode von lukas
spielt mein grab
ja wir haben gar keine nannte dieses
projekt hier waren wir das letzte mal
stehen geblieben mit meinem wundervoll
im haus am meer mississippi anlockt
check the recipe böckers zum fix ist ein
recipe burkhard danke so wird also holz
gemacht das lustig hat auch gar nicht
dass es hier in minecraft neuerdings von
ratzeburg gibt aber wurde okay ist cool
ihr wisst aber wieder bescheid hier
freunde beim heutigen video auch wieder
ihr dürft bestimmen ob ein dritter party
des projektes kommen wird weil wir
erster teil habt ihr halt 85.000 gleich
geschafft da ziehe ich wirklich meinen
imaginären hut für euch jetzt wegen
meine liebe luxus sage ich heute 90.000
live
wenn ihr das erreicht da kommt nächste
woche direkt ein neuer teil von
minecraft mit luca der name des
projektes ohne namen
allerdings starten wir jetzt nun erst
mal so richtig durch wir müssen nämlich
erstmal schweine töten
es tut mir leid an alle vegetarier hier
aber irgendwie musikrat überleben
das world record also wenn ein scheiß 50
millionen likes auf instagram hinkriegt
dann schalte apropos ich habe ja auf das
reagiert und habe mir dort auch
merchandise von demai bestellt
ilike hat sich gelohnt
eine wichtige ressource die wir hier in
minecraft erstmal benötigen wir sind
steine daraus sind natürlich schon
unsere werkzeuge und so aber auch
steinen können wir uns auch einen ofen
mache man mit dem ofen können wir unser
schweinefleisch beraten
das schmeckt dann ein bisschen besser
allgemein hatte ich mir vorgenommen dass
wir in der nächsten episode also im
dritten teil sofern ihr halt 90.000
daumen hoch schaffen sollte wollte ich
in eine mine gehen also in eine höhle
und da hab ich mir gedacht dass ich
währenddessen ganz gut eure fragen und
kommentare beantworten kann also
schreibt mir gerne jetzt irgendwelche
fragen oder kommentare et cetera über
die ich in der nächsten folge reden soll
und in die kommentare und dann ist euer
kommentar vielleicht in der nächsten
folge mit drin
das eigentlich für ein hässlicher bauen
schön hier mit einem scheiße turm
hochbau und freunde
dann können uns hier vorne das holz mal
ein bisschen weg laune weil holz ist
natürlich auch eine wichtige sache in
minecraft denn mit holz können wir uns
nix machen und wir können uns mit holz
natürlich auch unser haus
ist da gerade unter mir blatt
verschwunden ein paar sekunden später
ich bin ich den behinderten all die
sonne wieder unter die runde und hey
schön und morgen der baum ist ab gefällt
das heißt werden jetzt auch genug holz
gesammelt und können uns jetzt mit dem
holz erst mal einige place machen mit
dem place können wir uns kisten machen
was habe ich acht kisten noch lagerraum
allerdings würde ich sagen dass die
mission für die heutige folge auf jeden
fall ist dass wir uns ein etwas
schöneres haus baut ich finde den ort
hier eigentlich schon ganz schön für ein
haus und in meinem haus sieht auch
gerade sehr schön aus allerdings haben
wir da hinten halt diese wundervollen
großen berge und auch hier vorne
die hollywood hills deswegen würde ich
auf jeden fall sagen dass man erst mal
noch kurz dieses schwein getötet
no way sind das alpakas einmal ganz kurz
freunde ich habe schon jahrelang ein
microsoft mehr gespielt weil das sind
nein nein ich finde ich dafür deutlich
wirklich alpakas in minecraft taiwan
gibson dass das ist ja der komplette
wahnsinn guckt ihr euch an
ja hallo
lama umfeld teile alter erst mal
umbringen ach du heilige scheiße man
kann genauso teppiche aufsetzen das lama
ist ein 10 bar ist ihr das für den
transport großer mengen an gütern
genutzt werden kann das ist in den
bergen und der savannen hochebene
beheimatet und tritt in vier
verschiedenen farben auf ok cool es ist
quasi eine laufende kiste also ich
drücke wirklich nichts und
bis 14
slater
ich kann hier immer noch nichts
wie funktioniert die schweiz mit den
lamas während mein lama da unten wartet
kraxelte jetzt erst mal den berg hoch
und auch mein gott die sonne geht schon
fast wieder runter ich find berge
wirklich unglaublich schöne minecraft
also mit dem schnee hier drauf und so ok
ich meine es ist acht mal acht
pixelgrafik also keine ahnung oder
überhaupt schön finden kann hat er das
hühnchen hier ist echt lebensmüde noch
ein paar letzte stufen und wir sind oben
mein gott
[Musik]
leute dahin hatten wir zuvor unser haus
jetzt noch der rest von dem baum
und ich fühle mich wie bei
das geht schon relativ weit runter hier
ich fühle mich hier gerade wirklich so
ein bisschen wie bei könig der löwen ich
bin hier oben auf einem berg pen halt
jetzt gerade wieder in der kompletten
shows hütte aber da mache ich hier mein
fenster auf lka ist die kacke weg und
sieht dass hier leute
es hielt allerdings wie bereits gesagt
möchte ich mein haus ein wenig schöner
bauen das heißt ich setze ich hier so
einen großen fehler hin und fall runter
und sterbe fast ich bau mal kurz das
haus und melde mich dann so ein paar
minuten wieder 2000 jahre später also
sieht das ganze hier ist aus von außen
in etwa so ich weiß nicht was ich mir
hierbei gedacht haben wenn man dann hier
reingeht also hier kommen natürlich noch
fenster hin und türen und dach und so
dann ist es hier ja ein bisschen
höhenangst und kenne ich auch weil ich
mag's ganz gemütlich zu schlafen ja
keine ahnung ich dachte das sieht cool
aus ich mache mir hier drin gerade mal
ein bisschen kohle denn mit kohle können
wir uns mit sticks und fackeln machen
und dann können wir das hier so ein
bisschen noch ein bisschen ja macht den
raum immer noch nicht schön leider schon
ein bisschen stur essen
schon krasse eißendorf also ich weiß
nicht ob ihr wisst was einen dort in
minecraft ist aber das ist also das ist
ein dorf
in dem dorf leben wille jay kay
dorfbewohner und dort kann man sich in
sachen abziehen von denen weil die sind
nicht sauer wenn man in sachen cloud
hale aber was du hier was du das
übernahme auf das ja ja das bringt halt
echt überhaupt nichts dies lama falls
ihr genauere infos bezüglich des lamas
habt könnt ihr mir das immer gerne und
in die kommentare schreiben
hier sind wir jetzt auf jeden fall am
dorf angelangt das heißt theoretisch
zieht noch wie mein ja keine ahnung was
das sein soll auf jeden fall ist dass
sie das willicher dorf mit den netten
dorfbewohnern hier hallo guten tag ich
glaube die beiden am grab sex das hier
ist ebenfalls einen raum im willicher
dorf der hat allerdings auch gar nichts
was guckst du so blöd oft haben die halt
irgendwelche kisten in ihren häusern
stehen aber irgendwie sind die hier alle
ziemlich pleite
wie bescheuert haben sie denn gebaut
hier hier bei ihm zu hause ist hallo
hier hinten sind auch wieder heftige
berge also ja liebe leser das ist
natürlich ganz nett hier bei euch aber
ich weiß nicht ich könnte ihn halt ein
bisschen week laufen also nicht
marihuana sondern das hirn damit kann
man sich dann irgendwann brötchen backen
und dann muss ich nicht immer tiere
töten
hier alles schön abräumen das ist nicht
von euch ich habe die ganze karotten
selbst habe ich die gepflückt mein gott
er pflanzt wieder an walter ihrem bruder
das kann ich ja direkt wieder mitnehmen
neu ist das ist hier ließ bandarbeit so
man jedes mal wenn ich ihn seine karotte
klau kommt nämlich böse an
[Applaus]
es fängt er hier vorne wieder an alter
das ist hier wie ein perpetuum mobile
das ist wie wenn
der maximal weiter sonst funktioniert
das hier nicht
hallo
mit einem sorry back to you here decio
carrick
mal
ja was jetzt also ich glaube mit den
leuten hier werde ich keine freunde mehr
ich lasse euch den rest mal hier obwohl
bis ihr werk in slate noch schön so ein
bisschen den restlichen kramm
mitgenommen
sorry wir laufen allerdings direkt schon
wieder zurück zu unserer tollen festung
da oben ich finde unsere welt ehrlich
gesagt echt schön überall sind tiere
überall so kleine kügelchen auch so
große berge hier vorne ist mein lama
genau stefan gibt es denn fische in
minecraft also ihr merkt schon freuen
ich habe mein kreft wirklich lange nicht
mehr gespielt ich hoffe dass das für
euch in ordnung ist und ich hoffe auch
dass euch dieses projekt hier gefällt
die sonne geht schon so langsam wieder
unter deswegen würde ich den heutigen
teil an der stelle jetzt auch beenden
wenn euch dieses projekt gefällt und ihr
einen dritten teil minecraft mit luca
haben wollt dann wie gesagt 90.000
daumen hoch
und dann kommt direkt ein dritter teil
online schreibt mir gerne unten in die
kommentare einige fragen die ich im
nächsten video dann beantworten werde da
ich dort in eine höhle gehen werde und
dann ist fragen beantworten ganz cool
[Musik]
zum 1